[Musique]
nous nous adressons
l'ensemble des jeunes qui voient la vie
politique comme un effort de
construction et non de destruction et
qui font confiance au président de la
république pour transformer en
profondeur la société française faire
plus de justice qu'à plus d'équité
comment vous définissez-vous par rapport
à la majorité présidentielle et surtout
papa port aux républicains indépendants
nous avons un lien direct avec le
président de la république nous sommes
le parti le jeune de la majorité
présidentielle donc nous avons des
rapports avec l'ensemble des différentes
composantes et c'était d'autant plus
facile qu actuellement la situation est
très saine au sein de la majorité mais
nous avons avec les républicains
indépendants des liens privilégiés
puisque c'est le parti dont est issu
président de la république et qui est le
parti giscardien
[Musique]